- So Kanye West has said some
things about Pete Davidson.
♪ God saved me from that crash ♪
♪ Just so I can beat Pete Davidson's ass ♪
- He may be getting himself
into a world of legal trouble.
Now, unless you've been
living under a rock,
you probably have some familiarity
with the public fighting
between Kim Kardashian
and her ex and baby father Kanye West.
Now in the aftermath
of this bitter divorce,
fans and observers have expressed concern
about Kanye's increasingly
erratic public behavior
against Kim Kardashian,
his threats against
people like Kardashian's
new partner, Pete Davidson,
and feuds with comedians like Trevor Noah,
who criticized West's conduct.
So today we're gonna cover
the laws of harassment,
stalking and domestic violence,
and analyze to what extent
Kanye's eccentric bluster
crosses the line into
potential criminality,
and address the legal
measures that Kardashian
and Davidson could take
to protect themselves
and their children as well.
And what's going to happen to Kanye's kids
in the aftermath of this erratic behavior?
Now, even if you've never watched
the Kardashians' reality show,
the family's forays into
everything from music and politics
into popular culture have made it
increasingly difficult to not
keep up with the Kardashians
whether you wanted to or not.
But if you've managed to stay uninformed
about the Kardashians for
this long, well, too bad
because we're going to cover
what in the world is going on.
Now here's a brief
timeline of the KimYe saga
based on publicly available facts.
Now, Kim and Kanye began dating in 2012
before they formally
tied the knot in 2014.
The couple shares four children,
daughters North and Chicago,
and sons, Saint and Psalm.
Now, as the years went by,
West's struggles with mental health
began to spill into the public view.
And in November, 2016, one month after Kim
was famously robbed at
gunpoint at her hotel in Paris,
West triggered backlash and
confusion at his performances
by going on controversial
rants about politics and race
and then ending shows early.
Now, West abruptly canceled his tour
and was immediately hospitalized
for psychiatric evaluation
due to, "acting erratically,"
During which time he
was allegedly handcuffed
in the back of an ambulance
for his own safety.
West continued to generate
negative publicity for himself
when he told TMZ regarding
400 years of enslavement
of African Americans, "That
sounds like a choice."
Now he would admit in a 2018 interview
with the New York Times that
he feared that these comments
to TMZ would cause his wife to leave him.
And if that wasn't
enough, in July of 2020,
the music mogul took to Twitter
to announce his candidacy
for president of the United States
where he'd go on to
earn 60,000 total votes
as he missed the ballot
deadline by several weeks.
And then weeks after that,
Kardashian posted a lengthy
statement on Instagram
addressing her then
husband's erratic posts
and struggles with bipolar disorder.
"Anyone who has bipolar disorder
or has a loved one in their life who does,
knows how incredibly complicated
and painful it is to understand.
I've never spoken publicly about how this
has affected us at home
because I'm very protective
of our children and
Kanye's right to privacy
when it comes to his health.
But today I feel like
I should comment on it
because of the stigma and misconception
about mental health."
The marriage, however, would not last
and Kardashian formally filed for divorce
in February of 2021.
In December, 2021, Kardashian
petitioned the court
to declare her "legally single
and restore her maiden name",
declaring their marriage
"irredeemably broken down"
and "no counseling or
reconciliation effort
will be of any value at this time".
Kanye, who had just changed
his name to just Ye,
opposed Kardashian's motion
to be declared single,
arguing issues related to
custody of the children
and shared properties
needed to be resolved.
Now, replying to Ye's motion,
Kardashian told the court,
"I very much desire to be divorced
and that Ye's social media posts were rife
with misinformation regarding
our private family matters
and co-parenting on social media
which has created emotional distress."
And on March 2nd, 2022, Kim's petition
to be legally single was granted.
The divorce grew even more contentious
when Davidson and Kardashian
reportedly started dating
in late fall of 2021.
On social media, Ye
would alternate between
begging Kardashian to reconcile
and attacking her parenting style.
In since deleted Instagram posts,
Ye expressed concern
for his daughter North
appearing on TikTok,
claiming that Kardashian had accused him
of putting a hit out on
her and claimed Kardashian
was keeping his children away from him.
Kardashian fired back
at Ye for his constant
attacks against her and
criticized his purported obsession
with trying to control and
manipulate the situation.
Ye's vitreal towards Davidson
also spilled into public view
in the form of a rap based attack.
In the song "Eazy", Ye raps,
"God saved me from that crash
just so I can beat Pete Davidson's ass,"
which doesn't actually rhyme.
But anyway, in one music
video for the song,
the Claymation Ye kidnaps,
beheads and buries Davidson.
In a follow up video, an animated monkey
beats up Pete Davidson.
Now in early March, Pete
Davidson's friend David Sirus
leaked proported text messages
between Ye and Davidson
in which the SNL star
defends Kardashian as,
"Literally the best mother I've ever met,"
and confronts the rapper for his
months of harassing
behavior on social media
against Kardashian and himself,
telling Ye, "To grow the fuck up."
Davidson purportedly informed Ye
that he was in LA for the day
and offered to meet
privately to talk things out.
When Ye asked for Davidson's location,
"The King of Staten Island"
star sent a photo of himself
flashing a peace sign with
his fingers sticking out
and his tongue with the cheeky reply,
"In bed with your wife."
Ye proposed meeting at his Sunday service
but Davidson refused, suggesting that Ye
was more interested in
publicity than resolution,
and Davidson offered to help
Ye with his mental health,
reportedly telling the rapper,
"It's so sad to see you ruin
your legacy on the daily."
Davidson wrote, "Let me help you, man."
Highlighting his own
struggles with mental health.
"It's not an easy journey.
You don't have to feel this way anymore.
There's no shame in having a little help.
You'll be so happy and at peace."
Entertainers like Billie
Eilish and D.L. Hughley
began to weigh in on Ye's
threatening behavior,
sparking their own feuds
with the rap mogul.
And in a "Daily Show" segment,
Trevor Noah called out Ye's belligerent
treatment of his ex-wife,
describing the whole saga
as, "Terrifying to watch,
that exemplify the type of harassment
that so many women go through
when they choose to leave."
In response, Ye angrily attacked
the South African comedian
on Instagram with racial slurs,
earning Ye a 24 hour ban for
violating the site's policies
on hate speech, bullying and harassment.
Okay, so I think that
means we're all caught up.
Now we can talk about
the legal implications
of all of this erratic behavior.
Now in the face of Ye's
threats against Davidson
and the unstable behavior
towards Miss Kardashian,
some have advised them to
get a restraining order.
So what are the options when it comes to
protecting themselves and the children
when it comes to a restraining order?
Well, let's start with the basics.
A restraining order, also
called a protective order,
is a court order that
can protect an individual
from being physically or sexually abused,
threatened, stalked, or harassed.
The person the restraining
order is against
is called the restrained person.
The person requesting
the restraining order
is called the protected person,
and restraining orders can be
broadened to include family
or other household members
as part of that class
of protected persons.
As the name suggests, a restraining order
restrains the third party from
committing certain actions
against the protected persons.
And then one type of restriction
is a personal conduct order
which prohibits the restrained party
from any of the following actions,
including contacting the
the person attacking,
stalking, threatening,
sexually assaulting, harassing,
destroying personal property
or disturbing the peace
of those protected people.
And a protected person can also obtain
what's called a stay away order,
which is probably the
kind of restraining order
you're familiar with in the media,
where a restrained person has to keep
a certain distance away
from the protected person
or where that person
lives, their place of work,
the children's school, their vehicle,
and other important places.
And if that restrained person
violates the restraining order
then they may be sent to
jail or pay a fine or both.
Now, additionally, a domestic
violence restraining order
protects an individual
from abuse when the abused
and the abuser are or have been
in an intimate relationship.
And the abuse prohibited is not limited
to the actual infliction
of physical injury
or committing assault,
as psychological torment is also included.
And if the parties haven't dated
and don't have a close relationship,
then that falls under the purview
of a civil harassment restraining order.
Since Ye and Kardashian were married
and have children together,
Kardashian might be able to seek
a domestic violence restraining order
while Pete Davidson
might be entitled to seek
a civil harassment order.
Now just because Ye's outbursts have
mostly played out on social media
doesn't make them any
less potentially alarming.
On the contrary, Ye's escalation
on social media is typical
of patterns that translate
into real world abuse.
So could Ye's conduct actually support
a domestic violence protective
order from Miss Kardashian?
Well, if Kardashian shows that she has
actually suffered emotional distress
or fear of harm as a
result of Ye's conduct,
and that fear is reasonable,
then there's a decent chance a judge
would grant Kardashian
a restraining order.
And here there are several
things that constitute abuse
that would give rise to an order,
but what's most relevant here is that
making someone reasonably afraid that they
or someone else are about
to be seriously hurt
through threats or promises to commit harm
would qualify as abuse that would rise
to the level of a restraining order.
And under California law,
a credible threat means
intentionally saying something
or acting in a way that would
make a reasonable person
afraid for his or her safety,
or the safety of his or her family.
And a credible threat to violence includes
following or stalking someone,
making harassing calls,
sending harassing messages
by phone, email, mail,
or over a period of time,
even if it's a short time.
And a threat may be implied
by a pattern of conduct
and need not be explicitly stated.
Now some have questioned whether Ye's
repeated efforts to win back Kardashian,
even after she closed the
door on reconciliation,
constitutes stalking.
In December, 2021, Ye purchased
the house across the street
from his soon to be ex-wife's house,
purportedly so he could
be closer to his kids.
Now during a charity
event that same month,
West, while Kardashian
and their daughter North
was in attendance,
tweaked the lyrics of a song
to beg for his estranged
wife to return to him.
In February, 2022, Ye shared
a photo collage of Kardashian
and their children where he
publicly pleaded with her
to rekindle their romance,
writing in a since deleted post,
"God please bring our
family back together."
So is this stalking or a credible threat?
Well, this alone, probably not.
There are three common
defenses to stalking charges,
that one, no credible threat was made,
that there was no intent to cause fear,
and or three, that the activities
were constitutionally protected.
Now to date, there's been no indication
that Ye has made a
credible threat of violence
against his ex or their
family or that his actions
are calculated to cause fear.
Ye's efforts to win back
his ex on social media
are not coupled with what would normally
be considered threats to her safety.
So they likely fall under
constitutionally protected speech.
And while moving close to
one's ex can seem alarming,
this act alone is not going to be enough
to constitute stalking.
So Ye purchasing a house
to be closer to his kids
is likely not stalking in
the absence of threats.
Though it's potentially
possible that Ye's actions
could fall under the broader
umbrella of harassment
which includes threats of
violence that seriously scare,
annoy or harass someone and
serves no legitimate purpose.
And to constitute harassment,
the offender must engage
in a course of conduct
that would cause a
reasonable person to suffer
substantial emotional distress
and must actually cause
to the petitioner.
Kardashian has already filed a motion
in her divorce case saying that Ye's
social media posts were full of,
"Misinformation regarding
our private family matters
and co-parenting on social media
which has created emotional distress."
And according to one insider,
Kim has grown particularly
disturbed by her ex
when he alleged in a
mid-March Instagram post
that Davidson, "Will hook her on drugs."
This comment allegedly
alarmed Kardashians so much
that she hired security to
protect herself and Davidson.
"She's scared and is so jumpy,
she's really on her guard and making sure
she has security right now,
and has asked Pete to
also take precautions."
Now, California law allows parties
to get a restraining order against conduct
that disturbs a person's peace
even in the absence of violent threats.
And based on the publicly
available evidence,
it's possible that Kardashian has cause
for a domestic violence restraining order
against Ye for harassment
and disturbing her peace.
But what about Pete Davidson?
Can he get a restraining order?
And is rap music a criminal threat?
Now, if you told me last
year that I was going to
analyze rap music using
Claymation to simulate murder,
whether that could constitute a crime,
honestly I probably
wouldn't have questioned it
given how strange the
last few years have been.
But let's dive into this thing.
And as I mentioned, in Ye's song "Eazy",
one of the lyrics threatens to,
"Beat Pete Davidson's ass."
And in the first "Eazy" music video,
he beheads and then buries
a Claymation Pete Davidson,
and in the next video Ye
has an animated Davidson
beaten up by a monkey.
Now in response to criticism,
Ye wrote on an Instagram
post that art is therapy
and denied that he was making threats.
"Art is not a proxy for ill or harm.
Any suggestion otherwise about my art
is false and mal intended."
So, did Ye commit a
crime in his music videos
by threatening to beat up Davidson
while attacking animated
representations of Davidson?
And does Pete Davidson have any grounds
for a civil harassment
restraining order against Ye?
Well, Davidson's public statements
that he's not afraid of Ye is probably not
going to help his case
for threatening this
as criminal conduct.
Furthermore, the leaked text messages
between Ye and Davidson
purport to show Davidson
eager to meet Ye in
public to talk things out,
which undermines a claim
that Davidson feels stalked
or harassed or suffering from
actionable sustained fear.
And furthermore, the first
amendment gives a lot of leeway
to artists and gives a
broad right to depict
exaggerated violence
against public figures
so long as they don't directly
declare their intention
to actually hurt another person
or encourage others to do so.
Like when Kathy Griffin
controversially held
a mock severed head of
then president Trump.
It might have been in poor taste
and knocked her from the
coveted C list to D list
but it probably broke no laws.
Given Ye's denial that he
intended to threaten Davidson
and Davidson's lack of fear,
Ye's musical mutilation
is likely not a crime.
Now that being said, there could be some
really severe consequences for Kanye,
at least concerning his visitation rights
and custody of his children.
For restrained persons,
a restraining order
can have very serious consequences,
particularly in the context
of domestic violence.
And if Kardashian successfully wins
a domestic violence
restraining order against Ye,
he could lose custody
of his young children
and even lose the right to
be in their lives entirely.
California law has special rules
for custody and visitation rights
when it comes to domestic violence.
And a judge will treat your case
as a domestic violence matter if one,
a parent has been convicted
of domestic violence
against the other parent
in the last five years,
or two, any court has
decided that one parent
committed domestic violence
against another parent
or the children.
And in fact, under California law,
a judge cannot award
custody joint or otherwise
to the parent who
committed domestic violence
unless that abusive
parent meets the burden
to show among other things that custody
is in the best interest of the children,
the abusive parent committed a 52 week
batter intervention program
and has completed any court ordered
substance abuse counseling
or parenting class,
has complied with any restraining orders
and has not committed any
further domestic violence.
If Kardashian obtains a domestic
violence restraining order,
it's possible though,
not incredibly likely,
that Ye could lose all right to custody,
be subject to supervised visitation
or even be ordered to stay
at least a hundred yards
away from his ex and their young children.
Ye could be ordered to stop communicating
with Kardashian and Davidson both directly
and indirectly via social media.
And in fact, the family
law judge handling divorce
could order Ye to stop
discussing the divorce,
his kids and his ex-wife's
new boyfriend with the public
if Kardashian proves
that she feels threatened
or harmed by this conduct.
Now throughout this entire ordeal,
Ye has maintained that
he's always been acting
in the best interest of his children,
but if Ye doesn't get his act together
and stop with this bizarre
and potentially menacing behavior,
he risks losing his family forever.
Now with situations like these
it's always important to avoid
emotion and think logically,
which you can learn to do with
today's sponsor, Brilliant.
Brilliant is an online
learning platform for STEM
that replaces lecture videos
with hands on interactive lessons.
It's for curious learners
both young and old,
professional and inexperienced.
So if you'd like to exercise your brain
or help your kids with school,
Brilliant has you more than covered.
Now one of my favorite
courses is all about logic.
Brilliant's logic courses cover liar
and truth teller riddles,
logical fallacies,
machine logic and even
some strategic game theory.
And logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers need every day.
And Brilliant lets you learn by doing
rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures.
Learning through doing
is scientifically proven
to be the most effective
way to master any skill.
And the courses have storytelling,
interactive challenges
and problems to solve.
You will absolutely love it.
And within Brilliant's library,
you'll find courses like
calculus, linear algebra, math,
and that applies to trading and finance,
basically every scientific
and mathematical thing
that you would wanna learn.
You'll also find courses
on gravitational physics,
astronomy, and machine learning.
Now you can sign up and
start learning for free today
with the link that's on screen right now
which will take you to
brilliant.org/legaleagle.
And the first 200 people to sign up
will also get 20% off
their annual subscription.
So just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description to get 20% off
your subscription to Brilliant.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there, click on this link
to all my other real law
reviews for more legal news.
So click on this link or
I'll see you in court.